[Musique]
je vous fais braizat chevalier avec
ibrahim ingar président de l'association
1000 sourires et commandant de la
réserve citoyenne s'est vu remettre
l'insigne de chevalier de l'ordre
national du mérite
ce vendredi 12 avril à la villa du
département une médaille remise par la
sénatrice et conseillère départementale
nassimah dindar c'est un grand tri c'est
quand même la médaille de la france moi
je suis tout môme la deuxième journée
des bénévoles
y a pas de calcul en ce qu'on fait on
arrive quand on est bénévole on ne
choisit pas de devenir bénévole je veux
dire c'est là qu'à son histoire et puis
on s'engage au nombre des projets on ne
sait même pas c'est toujours très
compliqué
l'association 1000 sourires espère
bientôt parrainer son 10.000e enfants et
et on arrivera à parrainer le 10.000e
enfants si tout se passe bien très bon
ou fil des ans
ben c'est ben on arrive quand même à 17
ans de bénévolat je veux dire j'ai
commencé tout petit aussi c'est pareil
après au fil des ans il n'y a pas de pas
de secret je veux dire quand vous
travaillez vous êtes sérieux
moi j'ai toujours eu le souci de le
faire des choses bien pour pouvoir
toujours emmener d'autres enfants
derrière après avoir été fait chevalier
de l'ordre national du mérite
après la signature des actes
administratifs et après la remise des
cadeaux tous les convives ont été
conviés à partager le pot de l'amitié
dans les jardins de la villa du
département
[Musique]